[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire jusqu'où va la guerre
économique que se livrent les états unis
la chine et l'europe
comment l'extraterritorialité du droit
américain est elle devenue un pistolet
sur la tempe des entreprises françaises
comme alstom comme airbus
alcatel total ou bnp paribas pourquoi le
concept de guerre économique est il
complètement ignoré en europe en général
et à bruxelles en particulier pour en
débattre nous avons invité frédéric
pierre uci alors que vous étiez patron
d'une filiale d'alstom à singapour vous
avez été arrêté par le fbi en vertu du
foreign corrupt practices act qui permet
d'arrêter n'importe qui n'importe où dès
lors qu'il est soupçonné de corruption
vous avez passé plus de deux ans en
prison aux etats-unis dont 14 mois dans
une prison de haute sécurité en tant
qu'otage économique at on dit afin de
mettre la pression sur le pdg du groupe
alstom qui devra payer une amende de 772
millions de dollars et vendre la partie
la plus stratégiques d'alstom elle son
concurrent américain general electric
depuis vous avez fondé un cabinet de
conseil en conformité
baptisé icarian vous raconter tout cela
dans le piège américain
co écrit avec matthieu aron paru chez
jean claude lattès alors la guerre
économique on a l'impression que c'est
le point aveugle des gouvernements
français successifs c'est aussi
l'impression que vous avez
oui un peu avant la faire le saut il y
avait eu quand même plusieurs affaires
d'entreprises françaises qui a été mise
à l'amendé par le département de justice
américain donc au total technip alcatel
alstom était la quatrième et il a fallu
attendre la quatrième entreprise pour
qu' il ya une réaction française cette
réaction française a été assez bien
orchestrée depuis l'affairé alsthom a
été étrillé très tardive elle est là il
dit vous êtes politologue vous avez
fondé l'école de pensée sur la guerre
économique vous êtes l'auteur d'une
histoire mondiale de la guerre
économique chez perrin qui était la
première du genre que les chinois ont
d'ailleurs été les premiers à traduire
et plus récemment du livre le droit
nouvelle arme de guerre économique chez
actes sud ou comment les américains
déstabilise les entreprises européennes
la guerre économique là aussi les
français commencent à
à concevoir l'idée même qu'il puisse y
en avoir une
bah oui à cause de l'expérience comme
l'a dit frédéric pierru si il ya un
certain nombre d'affaires qui montre
qu'il va falloir enfin s'intéresser à la
pensée stratégique sur les affrontements
économiques
ça existe en chine ça existe au japon ça
existe aux etats unis c'est à dire qu'il
ya des membres de l'académie donc du
monde universitaire qui se posent des
questions sur ce que sont les
affrontements économiques aujourd'hui et
vous l'avez dit j'ai montré dans un
récent livre que pour moi elle commence
dès les olitique le concept de guerre
économique est aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que en europe en france on n'admet pas
l'existence tout simplement de la
violence dans le champ économique parce
qu'on dit en gros la violence c'est le
monopole du champ politique mais non la
violence existe aussi dans l'école que
vous avez fondé c'est une véritable
école elle les cornes des guerriers
économique mois ci une école de pensée
de réflexion qui ado c'est via son
directeur à l'école de guerre économique
qui elle forme des guerriers économique
dont les gens qui sont capables de
défendre des entreprises avec des
opérations défensives ou des opérations
offensives
alors commençons par sur
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
au départ c'était pour lutter contre la
corruption des entreprises américaines
et ensuite des entreprises de en
concurrence avec les entreprises
américaines comment ça
comment se fait-il au fond que seuls les
américains lutte contre la corruption
dans une vue de l'esprit
non mais c'est ce qu'ils disent et ce
qu'ils ne s'esquive une vitesse qui
veulent nous faire croire
en fait cette loi acte elle a été mise
en oeuvre en 1977 au moule lockheed
martin qui était un grand fabricant de
chasseurs
a été pris la main dans le sac à payer
des pots de vin un peu partout en europe
et au japon pour vendre leurs chasseurs
et donc à ce moment les américains ont
eu un show deux choix soit légiférer la
correction on ira la corruption c'est
possible comme c'était le cas en france
à l'époque de reuil française est allé à
bercy déclaré les pots de vin jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'an 2000 québec sur son sur son
bilan voilà donc c'était soit on fait
s'asseoir on criminalise la corruption
et comme c'est arrivé à un moment de l'
affaire du watergate ils n'ont pas eu
d'autre choix que de que de légiférer
sauf que les entreprises américaines se
soient trouvés défavorisés par rapport à
leurs concurrents américains parce que
leurs concurrents européens que leurs
concurrents européens continuer à faire
de la corruption et donc les entreprises
américaines ont mis une pression sur le
congrès pour que cette loi ne fait ne
s'applique pas et pendant plus de 25 ans
elle est restée tout à fait endormi ce
qui l'a réveillé c'est que des comme
disait ali il ya des gens qui ont
réfléchi à comment on allait pouvoir
utiliser cette loi qui était dormantes
et en faire un instrument de guerre
économique et en 1998 ils ont mis la
pression sur ce le congrès pour qu'elles
changent et c'est toi et pour que cette
loi devienne extraterritoriale donc s
attendait ça veut dire qu'à partir de
1997 cette loi s'applique à toutes les
entreprises dans le monde à partir du
moment où un rattachement minimale avec
le territoire américain
et ce rattachement ça peut-être
utilisation du dollar
des emails qui sont transitent par des
serveurs américains est encore pire la
dernière fois le au mois de juin dans un
cas ils ont mentionné que l'appartement
où il y avait un impact économique sur
les états unis il avait juridiquement
sur ces deux reprises lors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est vrai que ça
repart en 98 mais on remarque que les
grandes amendes vont elles tomber après
2001 pourquoi parce qu'en 2001 il ya les
fameuses attaques terroristes contre les
états unis et il a à ce moment là les
américains comprennent que pour lutter
contre le terrorisme il faut lutter
contre le financement du terrorisme et
donc le financement du terrorisme pur
repasse à la fois par la corruption ou
la violation de leur embargo et tout à
coup ils s'aperçoivent qu'ils ont des
outils formidables parce que ce sont des
outils d'administration pas à des outils
de la justice frédéric pillot chiffre
pourra nous en parler mais ils sont
actionnable par l'administration
américaine et donc à partir de 2002 ils
comprennent ils
10 dans des textes qu'il faut mener à
mener la guerre économique pour mener la
guerre contre le financement du
terrorisme
et ils vont actionner tout simplement
cette arme administratif puisqu'elle
passe uniquement par l'administration de
la justice américaine pour pouvoir
frapper un certain nombre d'entreprises
mais dans le cas de d'alstom il y avait
bien eu de la corruption
oui mais on a donné dit on avait
corrompu enfin on ait nice comme avait
embauché des consultants qui avait
corrompu c'est corsé consulta et est
embauché pour corrompre voilà voilà donc
effectivement il ya eu la correction en
indonésie la corruption dans beaucoup de
d'affaires il faut savoir c'est jusqu'à
l'an 2000 les entre 800 et à les
déclarer
les pots-de-vin à bercy à parts égales
en 2010 et la convention de l'oecd qui a
été mise en place en france via las la
première fois anti corruption et donc
les à partir de l'an 2000 un puissant
elles ne peuvent plus faire de
corruption mais les vieilles habitudes
perdurent dans beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de groupes pendant coup
beaucoup d'années parce que aussi en
france il ya pas eu de poursuites contre
les entreprises françaises donc les
américains se sont dit vous ne faites
pas le travail chez vous vous ne mettez
pas allemand de vos propres aux
entreprises pour des faits de corruption
donc une distorsion de concurrence sur
le marché international parce que nous
soit disant nous incluant nos propres
entreprises et donc comme vous fait pas
le ménage chez vous ou allez faire chez
vous alors justement vous vous êtes une
victime collatérale de la guerre
économique ou une victime collatérale de
la lutte anti-corruption a les deux je
positive
je ne suis pas du tout une victime ce
qui s'est passé dans l'affairé alsthom
c'est que
en 2003 effectivement il ya cette
affaire en indonésie donc à partir de
cette affaire en inde indonésie
les etats-unis eux ont tiré la cible sur
la pelote de laine et ont découvert en
fait tous les faits corruption que le
groupe avait fait un peu partout dans le
monde pendant une quinzaine d'années
il faut savoir que
publi t contre la corruption bien
évidemment tout le monde est d'accord
pour proposer des collections ce qu'il
faut voir c'est plutôt la symétrie des
sanctions prises par les états unis
contre les entreprises qui sont à pied
de corruption et là on voit une énorme
asymétrie entre les poursuites contre
leur propre entreprise et les poursuites
contre les entreprises étrangères
notamment européennes
vous faites la liste par exemple les
junies un peu de temps de regarder un
peu tout ça donc si vous faites la liste
des entreprises qui ont payé par exemple
de 100 millions de dollars d'amendé au
titre de cette loi f6 pied vous rendez
compte qu'il ya 32 et sur 709 vous
n'avez 19 européenne et que cette
entreprise américaine en fait en
pourcentage des entreprises américaines
payent moins de 20% des amendes aux
titres de leurs propres lois anti
corruption
et vous si vous prenez secteur
d'activité particulier on parlera de
d'airbus mais on peut parler de la
production d'électricité vous rendez
compte par exemple que tous les
concurrents de l'entreprise américain
dans le secteur de la production
électricité soit abb siemens alstom
itachi sont tous fâchés se passer par
les fourches caudines du fc piller tout
le monde a écopé d'amendés
vous prenez leurs équivalents aux états
unis genii trick racing à aux becs tels
serge oden le 10 black and me séraphin
la liste extrêmement longues en depuis
1977 les états unis n'ont pas senti une
seule société dans la production
électricité domestique
vous voyez les nazis mythes et des
sanctions parce que tout le monde et
concurrents sur les mêmes marchés
tout le monde sous un pont même appel
d'offres et ya pas de miracle mais les
entreprises chinoises sont visés aussi
férocement par les américains qui les
entreprises européennes est nouveau mais
oui oui il est clair je veux dire il ya
deux entreprises chinoises récemment
dans les télécommunications 7,3 web qui
sont poursuivis par soit le dj mystère
de la justice américaine soit par
d'autres plaintes d'autres autorités de
poursuites américaines et à chaque fois
c'est en effet en particulier pourquoi
ouais c'est pour le coup soit de
l'espionnage économique pour huawei soit
le fait que roy wen n'a pas respecté
l'embargo des états unis sur l'iran et a
fait des affaires avec l'iran
donc en effet il frappe les entreprises
chinoises
mais un peu surpris parce que je pensais
qu'il serait plus prudent mais
visiblement absolument pas et ils le
frappent en assumant totalement de fer
chantage sur elle s'avère que le
président trump a dit clairement que
c'est lui qui voulait frapper zte donc
géant des télécommunications comme froid
ouais mais c'est lui aussi qui
finalement l'a sauvée en autorisant les
entreprises américaines a continué à
faire du business avec avec était donc
on voit bien que la différence avec le
président obama qui dans la faire
paraître dans bnp a dit qu'il y avait
vraiment séparation entre la maison
blanche et le département de la justice
est bien en ce qui concerne 30 hne ans
est un outil pour faire pression sur la
chine est obligé la chine a signé ce
fameux accord commercial qui diminuerait
les ce qui est bien avec 30 chez qui il
dit il est clair il est très clair mais
il utilise des outils qui se voit là
depuis bien longtemps avant lui faire
des lois etc mais ils utilisent de
manière assez brutale et claire gauthier
non mais juste pour rebondir sur ce que
dit ali en fait la plupart des amendes
contre les entreprises européennes ont
été décidées sous l'ère obama
donc c'est obama qui est vraiment
industrialisés l'utilisation du droit
quand même des gars économique
sauf que on les met plus ou moins et
c'est le type de la sympathique dont le
dans l'opinion publique on lui donner
bon dieu sans confession
3 il ya au moins il est cash en fait il
dit tout haut ce que vos besoins faisait
tout bas et en fait peu importe qui est
adepte de l'administration américaine de
toute façon c'est une politique qui qui
a qui date des années 90 comme celle a
rappelé ali et qui se poursuivent
jusqu'à maintenant aller demain on va
changer de président ce sera exactement
la même chose mais moi j'adore 30 pour
ça parce qu'il nous réveille en tant
qu'européen là on peut plus masquer
derrière se cacher derrière le fait de
dire ok c'est peut-être il n'y a pas
deux il ya pas de fumée sans feu
peut-être il n'y a pas de vision
stratégique d'ailleurs fait il ya une
vision très stratégique et très
économique derrière être un peu le dis
tout la partie stratégique de d'alstom
qui a été vendu à être general electric
est ce que general electric dans votre
esprit était déjà dans l'idée qu' il
fallait qu'ils rachètent cette partie de
l'entreprise et que tout aurait été
ça aurait été une sorte de conspiration
entre general electric et le département
de la justice américain alors c'est
l'histoire de l'oeuf et de la poule
est-ce que c'est jen afrique qui voit
voyons les entreprises affaiblies par
des une affaire de procédure des
procédures de corruption se saisit de
cette opportunité et el harrach est où
est ce que tout cela et planifiés bien
avant avec le state department avec la
maison blanche avec le département de
justice
chacun aura son propre avis là dessus
parlons des faits sur les faits jean
eric essaie de racheter ashton depuis
plus de 15 ans sur les faits c'est la 5e
entreprise que general electric rachète
dans l'exact la même condition
l'entreprise et mis sous enquête par le
département toys pour enfreinte oev six
pieds le dirigeant risque sa peau et
génériques à cheval blanc pour racheter
d'entreprise et de dirigeants s'en sort
le dirigeant le carrosse n'était pas
vous hein sinon c'est le pdj le pdg du
groupe s'en sort sans une égratignure
donc il ya quand même un effet de
récurrence si vous voulez après cinq
fois on peut se demander quand même s'il
n'y a pas derrière une collusion au plus
haut niveau et d'ailleurs qui dessert
juristes de general electric qui après
s'est retrouvé juriste chez alstom a
déclaré sous serment devant la
commission marley à l'assemblée
nationale qu' à l'époque où il était
chez general electric
il était prévu en effet qu'alstom
tomberait à jour ou l'autre pour
corruption et qu'à ce moment là il
pourrait racheter à l'estomac
carlos ghosn dans sa défense a lui aussi
dit que après tout on avait monté une
affaire contre lui pour que les japonais
récupère la direction de nissan le voyez
comme ça aussi vous alors ce serait de
la guerre économique
oui moi je pense évidemment qu'il ya un
volet guerre économique dans cette
histoire là je ne jugerai pas la manière
dont il s'est comporté avec l'argent de
renault et de nissan et c'est ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est de voir l'ensemble
de l'histoire
à chaque fois qu après la seconde guerre
mondiale une entreprise étrangère de
l'automobile a été à la pointe au point
de prendre la première place mondiale
elle a été bousculée pour pas dire
autrement sa et étoile iota dans les
années
80 90 a été volkswagen avec la sphère du
diesel gates ça a été un moment renault
qu'à crier trop fort sans doute qu'ils
allaient qu'il prétendait être le numéro
un mondial et c'est dans la sphère
toyota dans la sphère du diesel guette
dans celle de renault il y a eu des du
biscuit donner à l'adversaire pour qu'il
vous fera évidemment le travail n'a pas
été fait au point de ne pas offrir le
bâton pour se faire frapper
c'est ce qui se passe dans la sphère
gones etc il était évident qu'un pays
quand même assez nationaliste sur son
industrie qui a perdu la seconde guerre
mondiale le japon qui s'est pris deux
bombes atomiques et qui a récupéré en
trois décennies
son économie qui a été capable de
menacer la première puissance économique
les états unis donc il est évident que
c'est un pays qui est nationaliste un
projet économique et que le fait de
crier trop fort qu'on allait absorber
totalement nissan
eh bien on a allumé les feux rouges du
côté de nissan et ils ont trouvé ce
qu'il y avait à trouver pour pouvoir
aller on dirait quand on s'intéresse un
peu à la guerre économique et aux
théoriciens de la guerre économique ce
que vous êtes devenus tous les deux on a
l'impression tous les pays sont toujours
nationaliste ans qu'ils considèrent
leurs économies les américains sont
montrés très nationaliste dans les
années 80 90 quand le japon les menaçait
les europe et notamment quand et
japonais ont commencé à mettre le pied à
hollywood les américains sont devenus 13
nationaliste et le sont les chinois le
sont les japonais sans qu'il n'y ait pas
de manière peut-être nous alors est-ce
que vous avez l'air de dire comme les
européens avaient regardé ce qui s'est
passé dans la fusion alstom siemens
c'est eux-mêmes les européens qui ont
décidé à partir d'un droit de la
concurrence qui date des années 90 ans
que la chine n'était pas rentré à l'om
c'est qui a dit ben non il ne faut pas
construire un géant européen des
transports ferroviaires
alors que évidemment en face la chine y
est un géant qui arrivent et qui va tout
bouleverser
donc oui l'absence de réflexion
stratégique le fait que l'europe se soit
toujours dit on s'est construite sur
notre norme qui est la paix surtout ne
pas parler c'est tabou de puissance ne
pas parler d'affrontement dit à nous
c'est la paix cette paix là va nous
permettre d'influencer le monde
non ce n'est plus suffisant aujourd'hui
il faut penser la france
bon économie alors moi je suis pas
guerrier économies mais je dis qu'il
faut le penser pour comprendre les
impacts de cet affrontement économique
et franchement il ya un continuum entre
les gilet jaune et l'absence de pensée
sur la guerre et comme dit pourquoi
ouais parce que c'est les dégâts c'est
le résultat de l'absence de pensée c'est
les gilets jaunes c'est le fait qu'on
des êtres humains désindustrialise la
france on désindustrialise l'europe etc
tout ça c'est un continuum qui va
falloir penser aujourd'hui est remarqué
le aujourd'hui l'europe est en train de
l'asthme et l'europe reparle de
protection des citoyens leur offre pas
de politique industrielle ce qui était
tabou il ya encore deux ans oui ils sont
ils sont en train de prendre conscience
à l'ofce sur le nationalisme d'abord
tout le monde et nationaliste sauf nous
oui mais on on a un historique en août à
un moment l'europe a su réagir
il y à peu près 25 ans les instruisent
européenne avait été aussi mise à
l'amendé par les états unis pour enfin
droit à la concurrence
à l'époque les européens avaient su
réagir de concert et avait émis des
amendes aussi aux entreprises
américaines pour les mêmes faits et
depuis sur le doigt la concurrence
chacun l'absence d'un châle de son côté
et même la commission européenne est
devenue leader on pourrait dire et
respecté dans ce domaine 25 ans plus
tard sur l'anti corruption on est
incapable d'avoir cette coordination
européenne
et c'est bien dommage parce que c'est
vrai que la france a réagi suite à
l'affairé alsthom nous avons créé la loi
sapin de on y reviendra peut-être autres
états donc en a eu on a une réaction
mais on est traître isolé en fait on se
rend compte que il très peu de pays
veulent une europe forte et la france en
fait partie mais moi je fais souvent des
conférences en allemagne qui devrait à
notre principal partenaire c'est dedans
dans cette lutte on parce que des
entreprises allemandes ont été mises à l
amende aussi siemens deutsche telekom
daimler etc de la même manière par les
américains mais il n'y a pas de réaction
de
de ce côté là et donc on est incapable
d'avoir une réaction commune et la
france est extrêmement isolées oui
airbus est leur évidemment tout le monde
pensait à un bus qui vient d'être
condamné à une amende de 3 milliards 600
millions d'euros
c'est un record dans l'industrie mais là
ils vont pas payer seulement aux états
unis vont payer aussi au royaume-uni et
la france alors 2 milliards pour la
france
900 milliards dont 2 milliards pour la
france 900 millions pour nos amis
anglais est à peu près 500 600 millions
pour nos amis américains
donc on s'est mis là ça y est on lutte
contre la corruption mais clairement
frédéric puis aux tirs faisaient
référence à la loi sapin 2 aloha sympa 2
de lutte contre la corruption arrive en
cette loi elle est la loi qui dit aux
américains
nous allons maintenant laver notre linge
sale en famille
laissez nous faire notre propre boulot
il est vrai qu'on ne l'a pas fait
lorsqu'en 197 la france signent la
convention de la cedeao sur la lutte
contre la corruption elles n'appliquent
pas ces textes
prenez un exemple la corruption en
pétrole contre nourriture
une vieille affaire qui date de l'ira
irak saddam hussein de la corruption
totale entreprises françaises condamnées
à 700000 euros
quoi c'est c'est les notes de frais des
trois premiers dirigeants on n'est pas
sérieux vis-à-vis des américains
donc évidemment il a fallu faire le
travail le travail c'est la loi sapin 2
le travail c'est la création du pnr nous
qui date d'avant puisque c'est la ferté
zag et le ps mais parti national
financiers et aussi la création de la
fin l'agencé française anti corruption
et ça marche pourquoi parce qu'en effet
sur l' affaire airbus 3000 3 milliards
602 milliards pour la france et le qui
va suivre
le fait que airbus va devoir montrer
patte blanche ne put faire de corruption
pendant deux ou trois ans c'est la fin
l'agencé française anti corruption or
dans la plupart de ces affaires
c'était une personne casino mais avec
l'aval du département de la justice
américaine
donc oui j'ai l'impression que les
américains vont peut-être nous
laissé faire le travail et voir comment
on réalise des décors peints kaouchi oui
en fait lorsque la sapad été créée il ya
dans la loi sapin 2 une provision qui
s'appelle la convention jusqu'en
l'intérêt public qu'est ce qu'elle
permet cette contribution à l'intérêt
public
elle permet aux entreprises françaises
de faire amende honorable de négocier
avec le parquet français un accord il
n'y a pas de condamnation pénale pour
l'entreprise ni à un accord sur laquelle
leur entreprise reconnaît les faits de
corruption paie une amende et les
entreprises ensuite ne sont pas
poursuivis
donc le prenne la première fois on a
vraiment utilisé ça dans la décade de
faire de l' affaire de corruption cdt la
société générale donc c'était des
enquêtes et des déjà commencer par les
états unis la société générale était
sous enquête pour corruption en libye et
donc les états la france s'est servi
d'un conventionnel d'aidés publiques
pour négocier avec le département
qu'elle tisse un accord ou l'amant n'a
été payé 50 % aux états-unis 50% en
france ça c'était l'année dernière
dans le cas d'airbus on a fait la même
chose là c'était tripartite avec les
années et au lieu de récupérer la moitié
n'a rien qui près les deux tiers donc de
devenir sur sur première donc l'idée
quand même étant la prochaine fois de
récupérer 100% comme le font les
américains pour leur font peur aux
entreprises de ne pas partager juste sur
la sphère total je sais un petit peu en
désaccord parce que total était déjà
sous enquête américaine il avait déjà
payé une amende dans le cas de la sphère
en irak aux états unis de 400 millions
donc la france
argy j'ai la même affaire donc là aussi
si on ne veut pas que les états unis
demain rejuge les affaires que nous
allons juger en france il faut aussi
appliquer ce qu'on appelle le non
système c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
être poursuivi deux fois pour les mêmes
faits dans deux ans on ne paye pour ça
c'est pas une loi internationale
c'est pas le voir l'échec mais déjà si
nous si nous mêmes nous l'appliquons
parents rue jean total sur des faits qui
est le pionner sur lesquels ils ont des
américains ont déjà statué
on va pas donner le bon exemple pour que
demain les américains ne rejugent pas
une affaire qu'on va juger en france
donc il faut aussi être très très très
très prudent sur ces aspects mais vous
pensez qu'un jour une on pourrait juger
une entreprise américaine
ça c'est tout le monde attend ça c'est
la prochaine étape c'est à dire que les
états unis c'est un pays qui comprend ne
comprend que le rapport de force donc à
partir de si vous êtes faible si vous
montrez vous êtes faibles ils vont
continuer à vous taper dessus
donc à partir d'un moment il faut
montrer que vous êtes un peu plus fort
et c'est ce qu'on avait réussi il ya 25
ans sur les lois anti cartel on avait
réussi à mettre des amendes aux
entreprises américaines et à rétablir
cet équilibre je pense qu'à un moment il
faudra il passait la loi sympa de le
prévoit de pouvoir poursuivre à
l'étranger une entreprise dont sa
filiale et est en france etc
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
le problème c'est que évidemment on n'a
pas la même façon de voir la justice
il faudra que le nexus le fameux lien
entre le territoire français et
l'entreprise théaud qui auraient
corrompu dans un pays étranger faudra
qu'ils soient beaucoup plus fort que ce
que les américains pluie parce que c'est
non seulement dollars mais ça peut être
un mail envoyé via un serveur qui passe
aux etats unis
je pense je pense pas que notre justice
ira jusqu'à la dent dans le cas dans le
cas de d'alstom la raison pour laquelle
le fbi a il vous arrête aux états unis
en 2013 pour ce qui s'est passé en
indonésie c'était quoi le lien y avait
un nexus parce qu'il y avait une filiale
américaine qui était qui était impliqué
donc on voit pas comment elle même avait
également corrompus
via une entreprise américaine qu alstom
avait racheté et donc derrière on a
continué à utiliser les mêmes
consultants que ça vous trompez
américaine utilisée par avant mais
pendant 25 ans 30 ans n'a jamais été
poursuivi par les autorités américaines
des décalages comme la racheter les
américains ont pour celui alstom
donc c'est ça aussi qui est ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre parce qu'il ya la
problématique de la corruption
et encore une fois les français les
européens n'ont pas fait le travail là
dessus mais la mangue la plus importante
c'est bnp c'est 10 milliards de dollars
et elle porte pas sur la corruption
elle porte sur le fait que bnp a décidé
de commercer avec l'iran le soudan etc
etc aux yeux des etats unis seul cet
interdit de commercer excepté absolument
pas aux yeux des autres institutions
financières internationales ni de l'onu
et le scandale il est là c'est que
évidemment la souveraineté de la france
comme dans l'accord sur l'iran est
entamée par le fait que les états unis
décident d'une liste de pays avec lequel
non seulement les entreprises
américaines n'ont pas le droit de
commercer mais toutes les entreprises du
monde n'ont pas leur compte et là ça
pose un vrai problème
eh bien on va aborder ce problème là
juste après une pause
[Musique]
cet accord c'est un accord politique
ça va bien au delà d'une simple guerre
commerciale
il est clair que la chine avait quand
même beaucoup plus à perdre que les
états unis je suis pas convaincu tout de
même que le jeu ne soit pas plus
équilibré qu'il n'y paraît vous avez un
certain nombre de secteurs d'activité
aux états unis qui ont été lourdement
impactés s'aperçoivent qu'ils sont en
train de perdre leur statut de
superpuissance et unique superpuissance
en la chine est un pays qui peut
beaucoup plus rapidement que n'importe
quel autre pays du monde se passer des
états unis et entraîné avec elle en plus
incertain d'autres pays européens que
c'est aujourd'hui la chine qui remet en
cause l'hégémonie américaine
[Musique]
c'est quoi pour vous une république
éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employés tonio la sphère
pin up fillon la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème parce qu'il
faisait tout ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et c'est sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation du citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les abus
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat avec frédéric
pierrot tu chies qui a connu les geôles
américaines
il le raconte dans le piège américain
depuis il a fondé un cabinet de conseil
en conformité icarian et avec ali saïdi
qui lui a fondé une école de pensée de
la guerre économique et dont le dernier
livre c'est le droit nouvelle arme de
guerre économique ou comment les
américains déstabilise les entreprises
européennes
alors on le voulait et est en train d'en
parler l'iran évidemment ça fait couler
beaucoup d'encre tout à coup des
américains ont déchiré d'accord qui
unissait à la fois les européens mais
aussi les chinois
et puis du jour au lendemain plus le
droit de commercer avec l'iran
alors justement c'était ça d'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien
c'était en gros vous arrêter de
travailler sur le nucléaire et en
échange de quoi on fait des économies
on fait du business avec vous hélas
aucune réaction pourtant à la pression
qu emmanuel macron n'a cessé de vouloir
convaincre le président des états unis
de changer d'avis oui mais ça n'a pas
porté
et regardez ce qui se passe donc en 2018
vous l'avez dit donald trump déchire
l'accord de 2018 à mai 2019
les iraniens respecte l'accord mais qui
ne respectent pas pendant cette période
là les européens c'est qu'ils arrêtent
de faire du business du jour au
lendemain
non oui ils ont trop bizarre quitter les
autres peur de menacer contre l'iran
qu'on garde en disant oui l'iran ne
respecte plus ses engagements en mettant
les premiers à ne pas avoir respecté
leur engagement c'est bien les européens
en refusant de faire du business et
évidemment en refusant surtout que c'est
ce qui intéresse les iraniens d'acheter
le pétrole récemment il ya des signaux
qui font très peur or à peine dix jours
une ou trois choses importantes en ce
qui concerne l'iran et plus globalement
la politique américaine de l'e-tron la
première c'est que on a appris par le
washington post mi-janvier que trump
avait menacé les européens de déposer
plainte contre l'iran sur l'accord ou
s'il ne le faisait pas d'augmenter les
tarifs sur les automobiles entre
européenne ils se sont exécutés dans la
semaine qui a suivi le ministre de
l'économie française bruno le maire a
suspendu la taxe aux gaffes
pourquoi parce que menace des américains
et de trump sur 2,4 milliards de
produits français correct est taxé à
100% dans la foulée le président entre
hommes a annoncé l'ouverture de
négociations commerciales avec les
européens et s'il ne le faisait pas
s'ils refusaient d'ouvrir des
négociations commerciales
alors il augmenterait encore une fois
les taxes
donc vous voyez qu'on a quand même un
président des etats-unis qui sait ce que
c'est que la guerre commerciale
il nous dit même qu'elle sait qu'elles
sont bonnes parce qu'ils les gagne et on
a en face des européens qui sont
pétrifiés qui ne savent pas comment
réagir face à cette pression et à ce
nouveau rapport de force et personne en
europe ne parvient à 1 tab lire un vrai
rapport de force avec l'administration
30 projets vous voyez comme ça aussi
oui le point ne sont pas les américains
à partir du moment où vous avez une
domination économique et militaire sur
le monde veut c'est d'imposer votre loi
dire en gros les anglais les français
ont dû faire à peu près la nouvelle
appellation de napoléon à fait la même
chose les anglais ont fait la même chose
les romains ont fait la même chose donc
rien de nouveau
le problème c'est notre réaction nous en
tant qu'européen là ça va très très lent
on a parlé de l'iran mais on peut parler
aussi du gazoduc entre la russie et
l'allemagne le nord stream 2 qui est
censé repositionner l'allemagne et le
reste de l'europe en gaz russe
les annales trump aussi à
dit qu'il allait sanctionner les
entreprises européennes qui
construisaient ce gazoduc donc où on met
des entreprises en fait si vous voulez
dans un conflit de lois sait capter un
moment où vous faites ou réaliser un
projet vous venez signer un contrat
il ya tout un tas de lois qui
s'appliquent à votre restrepo ce contrat
vous avez votre propre loi vous avez le
loi de la loi du pays vous avez la loi
américaine vous avez la loi anglaise on
n'a pas parlé mais les anglais font
exactement la même chose et un moment
vous allez devoir faire un choix en tant
que patron d'entreprise soient respectés
telle loi soit respectée tel autre loi
et vous allez forcément un moment de
voir chez quelqu'un vous fâchez vous
fâcher à quelqu'un le problème c'est
qu'on voit pas quand on est une grande
entreprise ou une grande banque prenait
l'exemple de la bnp tout à l'heure mais
vous pouvez pas vous fâcher avec les
états unis
appartenant ou la menace et de dire vous
ne faites plus de transactions en
dollars vous tuer la banque
donc vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que
en fait de respecter ce que la loi du
plus fort
c'est la même chose avec total lorsque
total se retire de l'iran parce que les
états unis ont dénoncé l'accord avec les
clients bien évidemment totale est
obligée de se retirer de lire parce
qu'il ya d'autres intérêts donc le
problème ne peut pas être réglé qu'au
niveau d'entreprise il faut créer une
une réaction politique et pour l'instant
on en revient toujours au même discours
c'est à dire que les chinois y
réagissent très vite on l'a vu dans la
sphère ou abri dans l'aveyron dans la
sphère et eux ils apprennent très très
vite parce que l'on peut nous pas ce
concept de l'extraterritorialité eux
seront quand même plutôt rester chez eux
pendant très très longtemps alors et
c'est un concept qu'ils ont plus de mal
mais il a su montrer les routes de la
soie ils sont en train d'appliquer le
concept d'extraterritorialité parce que
sur l'ensemble des routes de la soie
donc soient maritimes soient terrestres
qui passe donc pas par l'asie mais qui
vont aussi en afrique en europe et c'est
en amérique latine
ils font signer la plupart sont des
contrats de droit chinois et dont ils
ont créé en même temps trois tribunaux
arbitraux en chine pour pouvoir régler
les éventuels contentieux qui se
poserait sur l'ensemble de cette route
de la soie dont qui comprennent aussi
ses caisses que l'extra territorialité
et le fait aussi de noter le la notation
sociale de l'entreprise c'est ce qui se
passe en chine où l'entreprise qu'elle
soit chinoises ou étrangères va être
notées dans son comportement éthique
environnementale etc
en chine mais aussi dans le reste du
monde
là aussi c'est de l'extra territorialité
puisque les entreprises vont devoir
affronter leurs notes vis-à-vis de
l'administration chinoise
donc les les chinois observe apprennent
et applique sur l'application de droit
chinois lorsqu'ils signent des contrats
le long des routes de la soie
c'est pas choquant à partir de là moi je
ne sais pas vraiment
d'extraterritorialité c'est à dire que
lorsque nous alstom nouveau signons un
contrat pour reconstruire daya bay la
centrale nucléaire en chine on a
appliqué de lever le droit du contrat
c'était le droit anglais parce qu'on a
posé le notre droit aussi donc à partir
du moment où dans une négociation il ya
quelqu'un qui décide plus ou moins qui
est plus fort dans la nuit l'eau ce sont
eux qui décident souvent quelle est la
loi qui arbitre le contrat bon ça c'est
des négociations commerciales s'est pas
vraiment l'ecstasy du droit comme on
l'entend comme on le voit avec la loi
sur les embargos la fois sur la loi sur
la corruption ou derrière des valeurs
morales on applique une théorie de dans
les deux cas aussi bien eux aussi bien
sur l'iran que sur la corruption c'est
toujours la morale c'est toujours la
morale financement du terrorisme ou la
corruption etc
par contre sur la chine a contré à
prendre très vite ça c'était sur moi
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps en chine
c'est de ces derniers mois à faire des
formations aux entreprises chinoises sur
l'anti corruption ils veulent apprendre
comment c'est ce que j'appelle un
cabinet de conseil en conformité il va
se mettre en conformité avec la loi
ils réalisent que leurs entreprises sont
fragiles d'un point de vue sur ce tout
ces problèmes de conformité sont très
exposés et il ils sont arrivés à un
moment où ils pensent qu'ils ont à peu
près le leadership technologique dans
pas mal de domaines et donc le peut
mettre ça à risque en s'exposant sur des
problèmes de conformité non qu'ils y
seraient en train d'accélérer leur mise
en conformité de manière extrêmement
rapide peut-être même un peu plus rapide
que les que que les européens et ils
sont en train de réfléchir et regarde
beaucoup les français de ce que nous
avons fait ça pas de pour voir comment
au niveau de l'état réagir à l'extra
télé américaine je donne un exemple
quand même ça a été très très clair le
department of justice a émis une note le
1er novembre 2018 qui dit la chose
suivante donne instruction aux agences
américaines donc le fbi
c'est d'enquêté en priorité aux
entreprises chinoises concurrents
d'entreprises américaines pour enfreinte
à la loi fc pied américaine mais celle
là c'est clair c'est clair c'est public
c'est sur internet vous taper tous des
objets du china corruption bouton b là
dessus et chinois ont ont surpris ça en
face est donc là il y là ils doivent
réagir et les enquêtes prennent du temps
donc on aura un effet d'ici 2 3 ans sur
sur cette directive
mais cette directive est suivie c'est
assumer c'est vrai que c'était
formidable sur la problématique de dire
économique de la part de nos amis
américains c'est y publie je veux dire
ça commence en 1993 comme warren
christopher qui secrétaire d'état un va
devant le congrès est dit nous voulons
les mêmes moyens que nous avons eues
pour lutter contre l'union soviétique
nous voulons ces mêmes moyens pour
affronter la compétition économique
mondiale
donc voyez que le pivot est opéré dès
1993 tout ça ce sont des signaux même
pas faible en sont ils tellement elles
sont énormes et pourtant pas en face
l'europe n'a pas voulu n'a pas voulu
écouter ces signaux faibles et s'est
rendu compte tout à coup qu'il y avait
d'un côté un rival systémique la chine
et de l'autre un allié qui était de
moins en moins alliés qui lui faisait de
plus en plus mal alors quand même
s'étonner c'est l'absence de réaction
dites-vous de l'allemagne l'allemagne
est dans le collimateur des américains
le sait les entreprises allemandes sont
véritablement concurrentiel pour les
entreprises américaines et l'allemagne
ne réagit pas alors là c'est le sait le
syndrome de la défaite de 1945 un peu il
ya de ça il ya aussi le fait que en
allemagne vous n'avez déjà pas de loi de
loi anticorruption contre les
entreprises c'est-à-dire que les
personnes qui peuvent être incriminés
sont simplement des personnes physiques
il ya déjà pas de loi qui incriminent la
corruption contre les ans des personnes
morales dont qui sont déjà de deux
étapes derrière à la nôtre la fameuse
loi
simple 1 2 et puis surtout larmes
économique c'est à dire qu'à partir on
les allemands commencent à être à
émettre des velléités contre les états
unis ils ont manqué
des taxes d'importation de sur les
voitures allemandes donc là tout le
monde rentre dans le moins très très
rapidement parce que bien évidemment
c'est le levier que qu'ont les états
unis pour mettre le plus de pression sur
l'allemagne
mais ils sont coiffés parce que du coup
c'est en effet le levier de
l'administration tron c'est les
automobiles allemandes mais c'est le
même levier pour la chine c'est la chine
aussi sera pas content si par exemple
l'allemagne exclut totalement roi way
des marchés publics
alors la chine menacent les automobiles
premium à à lloris et aux crues logique
l'allemagne est coiffé méheut alors il
ya d'abord le lien transatlantique qui
est beaucoup plus fort entre berlin et
washington contre paris et washington
c'est très clair il ya une peur de
décevoir les américains qui est très
très forte
ensuite l'allemagne a pourtant une
tradition de guerriers économique un jeu
le monde dans le livre sur l'histoire je
dire la ans c'était quand même du 13e au
16e siècle des marchands allemands qui
étaient capables de faire des blocus
économique qui était capable de faire
la lignée des marches massives voilà
donc il ya quand même une tradition mais
l'allemagne à une autre ou terrible de
parler de la puissance quand bien même
ce serait la puissance économique donc
la marque la puissance allemande ça
beaucoup de difficultés mais ça avance
il ya des signaux qui montrent que ils
comprennent certaines choses le pour moi
le signal le plus fort c'est le fait que
les allemands ont été contraints
observatoire des investissements
étrangers en europe et bien entre temps
il ya eu la sphère kucka en 2015 tout
cas c'est une très belle entreprise
allemande de robots mais du robot très
très faim eh bien ils ont été rachetés
par les chinois et tout à coup ils sont
aperçus qu'on ait fait il était menacé
par des investissements chinois et l'ice
ont mis derrière les français et
ensemble ils ont porté à la commission
européenne la création du règlement sur
la surveillance des investissements
étrangers
or évidemment union européenne donc il
ya des signaux qui montrent qu'ils ont
envie d'évoluer
ils viennent nous voir pour traduire un
certain de nos textes aussi parce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils n'ont plus de doctrine
économique
donc il ya des avancées et je pense que
gamme sans être trop optimiste il ya un
petit axe paris berlin qui pourrait être
activé pour on rêve d'accès paris berlin
sur à peu près tous les domaines
oui au tce oui mais il faut pas se
cacher derrière derrière c'est non plus
je veux dire c'est pas parce qu'elle
n'est pas de réponse européenne il faut
paraît il faut pas réagir je pense qu'il
faut commencer par chez nous et on a
commencé avec les vrais sapins de il
faut là il faut la renforcer la gestion
la loi sapin 2 qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans
et pourquoi faut-il pourquoi d'etel pas
suffisante mais ce n'est pas suffisant
parce que les principalement défensive
on en a parlé tout à l'heure
pour l'instant le risque prince sur les
entreprises françaises le risque qui
pèse le plus aux entreprises françaises
des risques de passif c'est à dire qu'on
va regarder suffisamment rétroviseur on
risque de trouver des affaires de
corruption comme en gironde où ces
affaires de corruption dans le passé
surtout que certaines entreprises ont
déjà une enquête américaine corruption
active 1 c'est à dire qu'on a corrompu
des fonctionnaires à l'étranger pour
l'étranger pour obtenir des marges venir
de vue d'ailleurs cette petite
parenthèse
si on ne le faisait pas ou si on ne le
faisait plus on perdrait tous ses
marchés mais si plus personne ne le fait
pas ce que tout le monde a peur et des
sanctions américaines
il y aura plus de corruption bain
il ya beaucoup de
deux de mes clients qui et arrêtent de
travailler sur certains marchés parce
qu'ils se disent ça sont sur ce marché
là on ne peut pas travailler sans fard
de la corruption c'est venu et donc on
se retire du marché on se rencontre on
se retire du marché qui vient avec
voilà non mais c'est donc donc c'est un
peu c'est extrêmement vicieux donc mais
il faudrait établir c'était moi je vous
donne un exemple lorsque j'étais en
prison la deuxième fois les américains
ont refusé d'appliquer ce qu'on appelle
les le traité de transfèrement de
prisonniers c'est à dire comme j'avais
aucune famille aux états unis j'avais
demandé à être transféré en france et
pour faire ma peine en france
les américains ont refusé d'abdiquer le
traité entre la france et les états unis
parce que la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire soit cet homme derrière
est terrible et pas que je témoigne bref
donc l'ambassade de france s'est dit ok
on va essayer de faire comme pendant la
guerre froide
on va faire un échange de prisonniers
parce que les états unis avaient fait ça
avec les turcs et non qu'ils avaient
effectivement et j'en viens à priori
turcs ont abandonné la prise d'un ami
américain et donc le l'ambassade tout
fier d'avoir trouvé la parade revient
vers moi quinze jours après en maison on
a regardé
alors il ya 60 prisonniers français dans
nos prisons dans les prisons américaines
mais on n'a pas réussi tout un
prisonnier américain dans les prisons
françaises donc votre histoire de
transfèrement oubliez donc ça montre un
peu voilà il faut rétablir un certain
record de france et tant qu'on apparaît
tel ce rapport de force alors on peut
aller chercher un allié en allemagne
mais ça du temps mais ils rien ne vous
empêche d'aller chercher des alliés hors
d'europe
la chine est un pays qui a été très
sanctionné le brésil a été très
sanctionné l'afrique du sud a été
sanctionné la russie des sanctionnés
parfois il va falloir peut-être élargir
notre notre vue et essaie de trouver des
partenaires en dehors d'europe
non mais on en revient à la question du
début comme y'a pas de foncer
stratégique on sait pas comment faire
on a chaque fois on est en réaction or
là il faut être au contraire en
anticipation et on voit les réactions ça
a été donc le rapport gauvin et un
député et l'hérault m français qui a
proposé de se positionner par rapport
une réponse sur l'extraterritorialité du
droit américain
c'est quoi ces réponses c'est un il faut
autoriser les entreprises à embaucher
salariés des avocats et comme ça on
protège les avis juridiques d un recueil
des américains l'administration de la
justice américain n'a pas le droit de
demander ce qui est vrai c'est de lego
le privilège
ensuite on renforce la loi de 68 et
faisant 80 que les américains ont
baptisé loi de bol de blocage qui
interdit à une entreprise française de
livrer des informations économiques
stratégie à l'administration américaine
ce qu'elle a fait mais ouvertement
depuis un certain nombre d'années donc
renforcé parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
n'a pas été utilisé dire on a sanctionné
personne sauf un avocat il ya quelques
années qui s'est pris peut-être dix
mille euros d'amendé et c'est donc on
n'est pas sérieux nous non plus dans
l'application de notre droit et
troisième proposition c'est de taper
très fort contre le cloud à acte c'est
ça c'est pour le coup c'est une loi qui
avons signé le président trump en ou
et qui dit tout simplement et bien que
vos mémoires que vous êtes soit hébergé
aux états unis où partout dans le monde
toute autorité de poursuite américaine
peut aller fouiller dedans donc amazon
facebook etc
les entreprises pensent que leurs
données sont bien en sécurité parce
qu'elles sont les serveurs sont en
europe
et bien non le cloud ac mais non c'est
dans le cloud c'est dans le cloud donc
n'importe quelle autorité de poursuite
américaine peut aller fouiller dans les
petits secrets des entreprises hélas le
rapport gauvin propose vraiment un
conflit de lois d'obliger
les hébergeurs facebook amazon etc à ne
pas se soumettre à une demande de
l'autorité de poursuite américaine ou
alors serait frappé par la loi française
oui après tout qu'est ce qui nous
empêcherait nous aussi de dire on peut
aller fouiller dans votre cloud à vous
ça on en attendant d'être encore là on
est toujours dans une position de
défensive et jamais dans une position
offensive sa vérité c'est une question
de moyens aussi oui technologie une
question de moyens en fait le club et
moi j'ai une vision un peu un peu
extrême peut-être mais on a tous oublié
d'affaires snowdon qu'est-ce qui est
calé 10 ne donne lui avait dit que la
nsa travail avec 100 entreprises du
numérique américaine
donc le google facebook etc pour
fonctionner toutes les données
numériques de tout le monde en fait des
entreprises des individus sms emails
télé pour la chanson téléphoniques tout
tout tout et notamment il y avait un
volet économique qui disait la chose
suivante notamment sur les entreprises
françaises qui disait que les
entreprises toutes les entreprises
françaises qui négocier des contrats de
plus de 100 millions de dollars était
systématiquement sous écoutes de la nsa
donc ça veut dire tous les cadres
d'alstom d'airbus et sert à tout on est
écouté par la nsa pour savoir comment
négocier ces essais contre elle donc il
ya eu la force nous donne entre
guillemets des américains ont été pris
la main dans le sac et donc quatre ans
après ils vont simplement légiférer le
projet de l'année ça déménage via ce
club
agde ce parce que ce que naquit la
chaussure des en fait une demande à
partir d'une demande d'un procureur du
département en justice chez microsoft ou
chez amazon et terra vous avez
l'obligation microsoft amazon de me
donner les données que vous héberger
dans le club sans passer par la
coopération unissant la justice
américain dans le mystère qui a eu six
français qui devrait être la route
normale de coopération si il y avait
dans les entreprises françaises qui
étaient sous enquête américaine
donc là il bâille pascal complètement la
coopération
deux mystères à ministère en s'adressant
directement à celui qui héberge de
données et donc là en fait c'est la
porte ouverte à tous les abus possibles
parce que les procureurs aux etats unis
ces deux départements de vue c'est le
département et l'état américain mais ça
va plus c'est toute autorité de
poursuite américaine voilà c'est à dire
qu'une police du texas peut demander à
ce qu'on aille fouiller dans le cloud
pour récupérer des données d'une
entreprise européenne etc
donc c'est vraiment très très large
notre but est seulement également d'un
particulier
il filait ce sera un particulier est ce
que c'est ce qui traceront et donc on
attend la la la la directive ou le
règlement de l'union européenne de la
commission y est vide et qui devrait
normalement s'opposer à auckland actes
et interdire cet espionnage systématique
de nous donner faye pour l'interdire ça
ne changera rien leur accord fort et il
nous protège et le rapport de forces est
à dire qu en effet si l'hébergeur parce
que dans le texte de cloud à l'hébergeur
n'est pas obligés de prévenir la
personne chez qui elle a fouillé
donc si l'hébergeur ne prévient pas on
peut l'obliger au moins à prévenir son
client que l'autorité de poursuite
américaine lui a demandé des données d
information sur l est c est donc fois un
conflit de lois pour rétablir un rapport
de force il y à s'habiller la réflexion
qui doit être fait dans les entreprises
se dire une partie de mes informations
mais informations des plus hautes est
stratégique je vais les garder chez moi
dans un club français
il ya plusieurs fournisseurs de cloud
deux clubs français qui ne sont pas
soumis au cloud act américain
donc là c'est cette réflexion on le voit
moi je vois beaucoup d'entreprises qui
aidera patrie beaucoup de leurs données
sur des serveurs français alors il ya
peut-être pas les mêmes fonctionnalités
que chez google amazon etc
mais au moins il ya plus de sécurité et
je n'ai vraiment plus de sécurité est ce
que c'est véritablement étanche parce
que l année ça quand elle écoute
téléphone du président de la république
française le téléphone il est français
tous les français mais les coudes quand
même genou théorique mais au moins
juridique mandat ils sont dans
l'illégalité là au moins avec le cloud à
qui ils ont le droit de se targuer
d'être dans l'illégalité
voilà ce que c'est quand même il sait
que c'est quand même une grande
différence
mais là encore c'est surtout ce qui est
problématique d'accès aux données
on n'a pas vu les signaux faibles dire
dès 2000
en 2000 il ya deux rapports du parlement
européen sur le système d'espionnage
américain des entreprises européennes de
parlement européen ces rapports qu'on
s'appelle et sion il ya aussi en 2000
une tribune de james woolsey qui a été
directeur de la cia de 93 à 1995 et
quitter une tribune qui est titré why we
spies oraliz pourquoi nous espionner nos
alliés tout était là tout était sur la
table pour pouvoir réagir et aujourd'hui
bas on est un peu les bras ballants et
on ne sait pas comment expliquez vous
cette absence totale de réaction ccd la
résignation de la faiblesse c'est de
l'incompétence et l'ignorance alors sa
mairie manque d'un truc d'anticipation
c'est le fait qu'on est totalement fâché
avec la technologie qu'on l'a abandonnée
aux américains et qu'on veut plus
réfléchir c'est on n'arrête pas de nous
le dire les gens qui nous gouvernent
mais amener beaucoup de fonctionnaires
ne connaissent rien à la technologie
ce serait vrai vous avez reçu emmanuel
todd vite vous souvenez ce qu'il a dit
sur l'absence de pensée sont de
crétinisation des élites etc
il n'y a plus de pensée même pas sur la
problématique de la guerre économique
qui a pu le penser il ya plus de
stratégie il ya plus de projets pour ce
pur
pour l'avenir donc à partir de ce moment
là on peut pas comprendre je veux dire
nous européens on est resté sur la
conception d'adams lice du marché le
marché c'est un acheteur qui rencontre
un vendeur et les deux possibles même
niveau d'information donc ça mais eux
les anglo saxons ils sont passés à la
conception de l'école néoclassique néo
libérale celle d'alec qui dit mais non
c'est pas du tout ça le marché c'est
tout le contraire
le marché c'est justement le lieu la
concurrence et c'est celui qui possède
la meilleure information qui remporte la
mise
vous voyez que notre notre combat est
resté bloqué sur il ya trois siècles
avec montesquieu le doux commerce etc
alors que leur vision à eux aux anglo
saxons n'est pas seulement besoin de
saxon vers les japonais les russes etc
sont sur une vision du fait que
l'économie c'est aussi un champ
d'affrontement et non on est c'est vrai
un peu bisounours sur ces questions là
avec période hachée oui et le
gouvernement américain en fait est là
pour défendre les entreprises
américaines c'est là leur principale
vocation et donc ils ont mis ça en place
depuis depuis extrêmement longtemps
un autre exemple ils sont extrêmement
interventionniste
on l'a vu dans la crise des subprimes
par exemple on parle de zhenhai trick
avant tout c'est une banque qui
s'appelait jean capitole qui faisait 85
des revenus du du groupe du capitole a
été heurtée de plein fouet par la crise
le gouvernement américain a injecté 139
milliards de dollars dangi capitale pour
sauver jean sinon c'était alston sigrist
et passé ce n'était pas le contraire
donc vous voyez qu'il arrive à préserver
leurs intérêts dans des domaines
stratégiques et de notre côté on a les
européens qui disent ben nous on n'est
pas interventionniste du tout nous
on laisse le marché décider royer
muscleront voilà pourquoi allons-nous à
intervenir dans un opération de rachat
d'une entreprise privée par une
entreprise privée on n'est pas le
venezuela ce genre de phrase on est
complètement déconnecté de la réalité
les internes avec un son très
interventionniste les chinois sont aussi
celles des russes en train d'interroger
ce traité les japonais les anglais sont
en fait tous les allemands un peu moins
mais nous on est en se laisse en fait
acheté nos pépites on regarde si vous
regardez toutes les entreprises
françaises qui ont été vendus ces
dernières années alcatel technip alstom
dans les domaines clés la production
d'électricité les télécoms tout ça c'est
parti mais une fois que c'est parti
c'est très compliqué de recouvrer notre
souveraineté devancé sur ces sujets là
oui je vous prendre le cas d'alstom ont
fabriqué quand même toutes les turbines
pour toutes les centrales nucléaires
électricité ici elle est produite à 115%
parler des centrales nucléaires
françaises
toute la maintenance de toutes nos
centrales nucléaires de toutes les
turbines sont maintenant dans les mains
des américains
ils ont si lewis est allé sous marins
nucléaires et les soumet un éclair donc
vous souvenez peut-être en 2003
lorsqu'on nous n'avons pas suivi des
américains dans la guerre en irak
tu vas sur le portail bleu il nous
saoulent on fait un chantage impact sur
le porte avions déjà arrêté nous fournir
des quatre buts pour notre portable dans
notre portail on était à quai demain on
ne les suit pas dans l'eau une prochaine
guerre qu'ils décideront en iran ou
autre part ils ont des moyens de levier
absolument incroyable sur notre économie
et c'est sur deux sous marins nucléaires
finition et sur notre production
d'électricité
donc il faut redéfinir ce qui est
important pour un pays il faudra revenir
un peu que le colbertisme il faut
redéfinir
mais ici il faut redéfinir certains axes
stratégiques et les défendre et les
protéger
nous les pays le font actuellement l'aja
mais le fait les anglais russie de fait
les jeux je vous interromps l'émission
se termine je veux remercier tous les
deux d'y avoir participé merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]